the oculus quest is an all-in-one VR
system that can be played almost
anywhere it doesn't need cords or a
console to work which means it's the
perfect system for beat Sabre if you've
played beat Sabre before you're probably
already addicted but if you haven't
let's get you caught up beat Sabre has
been out for a year now and they've
released DLC packs with new songs so
there are tons to try but here are a few
we really like with the oculus quest you
will probably play a ton of beat Sabre
because of how easy it is to play
anywhere but here are a few things to
know before you go down that beaten path
beat Sabre has a practice mode that
really helps you improve by allowing you
to slow down each song so you can
memorise the more difficult moments use
it if you get stuck on a song that you
really want to master all of the best
players of the game find their favorite
way of holding their controller the
oculus touch controllers are very light
and comfortable to hold but you can find
a unique way to grip them that increases
your accuracy and comfort during hours
of savoring each song or map has an
adjustable difficulty rating from easy
to expert in beat Sabre the hardest
versions of the songs are on expert plus
difficulty which increases the notes you
have to hit by about 500 percent
compared to easy difficulty expert plus
also increases the speed at which the
notes jump towards your screen by about
60% which gives you less time to chop
more blocks you can build towards
mastery of the entire catalog of songs
but here are some of our favorites to
get you started
legend is one of the first beat game
songs to go viral online it was popular
before the DLC it's on was even released
in the game the lyrics are easy to
memorize and sing along to while you're
trying to become a legend in your own
right while alone in your living room it
has a relatively low beats per minute
but quite a lot of notes flying at you
so the energy level stays right in the
middle it's a great song to savor
[Music]
Escape is an awesome track it will
really get your blood pumping because
the amount of ducking while blocks are
flying at you at high speeds the
obstacles really feel immersive to dodge
in the oculus quest headset and you can
really get into the leg day workout
potential don't let the name fool you
this track is no breeze it will call
upon your drumline skills by making you
slice in different directions with each
hand it's a great track to practice on
because as you move forward unto the
expert + difficulty the opposite
movement with each hand skill is going
to be absolutely required another song
that's good at introducing you to a
skill is unlimited power the track is
known for its cross slicing sections
that switch up colors on you at the last
second to keep you on your toes for the
whole song as you up the difficulty the
increase in the notes per second really
adds to the cross slicing challenge
roman bass is just fun the tune has this
rad piratey feel that will keep you
engaged in the slicing pattern of blocks
causes you to rock from side to side the
challenges of the map are varying speeds
and a combination of dodging cross
swiping and movement get your
swashbuckler on baby
the oculus quest is available now in a
64 gigabyte 128 gigabyte version thank
you so much for watching remember to
savor the moment
you